please welcome Academy Award winner Cher
damn let's dress okay don't pay any
attention to anything that's going on
below money's okay and now for Best
Original Song
all right you probably noticed already
that I am dressed like a grown-up no no
I wish to apologize to the Academy and I
promise that I will never do it again
and the Oscar goes to the Oscar goes to
Phil Collins for you
how my life can go on I think well it's
been hell I tell you um you don't know
what this means to me hey you don't know
what this means to my kids
it's fantastic um I got some people to
thank I'd do it quickly I promised my
friends at Disney who helped did all the
work on Towson Bonnie Arnold Kevin Lima
Chris buck producer and directors Chris
Montaigne who is just an incredible guy
music producer Peter Schneider Tom
Schumacher brilliant minds mr. Glen
Keane and all the animators of course
who did it too wonderful job um uh Mark
mention he did a wonderful job on the
score and Rob Cavallo helped me produce
the record my manager Tony Smith my
agent Hilary's sure my family my lovely
wife oriane man this is tough I didn't
think this would be as tough on my wife
or am mr. temporary and my wonderful
kids Lilly Jolie and Simon who really
wrote this song for me the Academy thank
you for making all the films that I've
watched and enjoyed and thanks for
having me here and this is fantastic
coming up Arnold Schwarzenegger uma
thurman ethan hawke and the Oscar for
Best Supporting Actor stay tuned